[Musique]
bonjour pâle thomson bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin avec
nous sur arte franceschi a commis une
grosse erreur dominique rab en n'étant
pas là alors qu'il y avait ce retrait
d'afghanistan d'ailleurs comment ça a
été perçu en grande bretagne ce retrait
d'afghanistan
la première question c'était une erreur
certainement il il en paie le prix
aujourd'hui
je dirais en même temps que c'est une
sorte de non événement c'est à dire que
c'est une erreur de jugement qui
ne veut pas dire que ce quelqu'un
d'incompétent de pas sérieux et
d'ailleurs
il il un petit trac éducation par
rapport à votre présentation il n'y
avait pas de premier ministre adjoint
auparavant c'est quelque chose de
nouveau qui lui a été donné
iyer impôts pour montrer que boris
johnson a quand même confiance en lui
mais il sait que maintenant quand même
rétrogradation est alors comment ce
retrait at-il été perçu ce retrait
d'afghanistan
c'était pas trop deuxième question cela
comme un
donc tout l'été occidentaux impliqués
l'allemagne les états unis le canada la
france
c'était considéré comme quelque chose
d'assez désastreux souvent soulevant des
questions en ce qui concerne les
rapports avec les états unis y compris
on peut voir une unis a permis des
personnes qui normalement
prône une relation étroite entre loi est
muni et et les états unis alors comme
autres dossiers il ya la crise à vienne
on vient d'en parler il ya aussi le co
vie dans la crise post commises il ya
notamment le ministre de l'éducation qui
a été l'un des premiers à annoncer sa
démission
aujourd'hui on cette crise post coït
c'est quoi les défis de ce nouveau
demain
mais justement vous faites bien d'en
parler parce que
l'un des buts ce remaniement
n'est pas de tout il réfléchit je pense
que son son objectif est de relancer le
travail du gouvernement a est de
permettre de
[Musique]
dépasser en quelque sorte de locaux
vides pour
revenir au programme de reconstruction
du pays du relèvement du pays boissonnat
été élu pour cela pour le président bien
sûr mais aussi pour reconstruire le pays
et en mieux comme comme comme il dit et
il a une équipe encore plus reçu dès
aujourd'hui très compétent qui est en
ligne sur les grandes orientations de
traits propres sites et et des personnes
comme beaucoup de ministres clés avec
beaucoup de personnalité et une capacité
démontrée
de délivrer comment dû à un mauvais
français par exemple le nouveau ministre
de l'éducation sur zavvi a été
crédité d'avec un autre avec cohésion
avec le grand succès du programme de
vaccination
au royaume uni et à l'éducation à tant
de nuits de meilleures performances que
celles de de monsieur wilson technique
est parti le royaume uni qui acquit à
vacciner 80 % de sa population assez
rapidement ça fait beaucoup de jaloux en
europe c'est ce bilan de la crise
sanitaire est ce que boris johnson le
paye un peu on voit que les sondages ont
baissé en tout cas pour ce qui concerne
la popularité des conservateurs
fait comme chacun sait les les sondages
varie dans le temps je n'ai pas
l'impression que le
le parti conservateur mal en point ou au
contraire
[Musique]
honnêtement je n'ai pas vu de sondages
moi même où les trains de travail sont
devant mais j'ai peut être raté quelque
chose sur les derniers mois les
conservateurs ont été généralement
devant
avec une marge
rite receipts par rapport à
juste après l'élection c'est sûrement
pour ça c'est normal c'est le jeu normal
d'un système démocratique je pense que
ce qui compte c'est que portion de cet
homme le premier ministre qui qui a
beaucoup beaucoup de personnalité il est
apprécié comme quelqu'un qui arrive à
faire des choses il n'est pas du tout en
fait un produit là haut up au contraire
une véritable stratégie inventeur de
véritables convictions et je pense que
cette largement reconnue même par ceux
qui sont ses adversaires politiques donc
genou pour moi le ni le gouvernement ni
le parti conservateur ne sont pas en
situation de difficulté particulière en
ce moment ils ont comme tu les
gouvernements des grands et occidentaux
beaucoup de défis à relever sur le plan
sanitaire toujours encore aujourd'hui
sur le plan économique et en matière de
politique internationale la situation
est également très compliqué car il ya
beaucoup de pain sur la planche mais il
est justement le premier ministre qui a
des idées claires il ya beaucoup de
volonté et qui a une équipe
composée de personnes qui sont ou qui
sont très capables d un bon niveau
intellectuel je dirais et et beaucoup de
volonté aussi donc honnêtement je pense
que c'est plutôt une équipe canaux et
qui est perçu comme étant
comme étant
plutôt tout aux fortes et il est
dynamique merci beaucoup paul thompson
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce matin
dans la matinale de rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes pluie ce président de
la section parisienne du parti
conservateur britannique